this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
we live in a time spent economy things
are competing for
your time and we obviously you can
always get more money but you can't get
more time so time is the finite resource
that we all share
and there's it's the ultimate neutral um
you know flat
leveling leveling playing field that we
all have to operate on
and if you have companies competing for
that you're going to end up with these
problems we're the the resource that is
being strip mined
into our you know our cognition and and
that means that we're worth more
if we're addicted distracted outraged
narcissistic attention-seeking polarized
and disinformed
than if we're a thriving citizen or a
healthy growing child who's
you know living their lives in the way
that we want and i think this speaks to
some of your work andrew because it's
about dignity it's about are we the
product
where we're just a cog in the economy or
do we fundamentally have dignity
and can we have a system that treats
each of us with a kind of sacred dignity
that that it should work that way yeah
it's about do we work for the economy or
does the economy work for
us uh you know are we worth more outrage
than calm it's like well maybe i'd still
prefer to be calm even
above worth more uh outraged uh you know
we have to
see to it that we're not all just
instruments of
profit and revenue maximization because
it turns out
maximizing our profitability is really
bad for us
[Music]
we're live welcome back andrew recording
this
on thursday morning you guys are getting
on your monday andrew just had a late
night after the vp debate
uh it won't be timely um when you guys
hear this but um unless something breaks
over the weekend we'll
hop in but andrew just quick vice
presidential debate
thoughts how do you think it went from
your perspective in the studio i thought
that
it was a great night for kamala on the
dems because you didn't have some
race uh changing moment
which really was the mission uh you know
if you look up
where things are trending very very
strongly towards
uh joe and kamala and so you just didn't
want to do anything to change that
right now the the news that's come out
today is
whether or not and by monday who knows
um whether there'll be a next debate
um where the debate commissions have
come out and said that uh hey it should
be virtual
so they're suggesting that it's going to
from the same building like they're
gonna stick them in studios
in the same concert hall in miami uh and
then trump immediately said
i'm not doing virtual uh and
so that's where it is so there might not
be
a next debate uh and then when i i
posted that story saying like hey you
know
not unsure what the next debate looks
like someone immediately responded to my
thread
we know that's not why trump is
declining or it's like someone suggested
that he might still be
um suffering some ill effects uh so
uh regardless of what you think the
uh in the catalyst i i take everything
at face value where like i don't think
joe wants to trump uh debate
someone who has coveted like you know
which makes sense i mean you know joe
joe's in a high-risk population and
there are a lot of
strange contacts that that are happening
um
backstage where like trump would come in
with you know a massive coterie of
people into the building
like joe has a massive coterie of
building uh kodu people so like
it's very hard to um to control for
everything so joe's like hey don't want
to debate
uh trump if he's got covered in a doctor
or say this is not a good idea
so the next debate is scheduled for the
15th that's this thursday guys
um i agree with you i don't think it's
fair to subject
one candidate to covet you know i'm
saying i don't think it's a fair thing
you have to debate that person that has
pandemic level contagiousness um
uh so virtual makes sense uh trump might
and also if trump is sick
i think it's also fair to reschedule
like you know like the human element of
this like
um whether it's his fault or not
that would be a fine place to land
because then um doctors could then
uh be a hundred percent confident that
trump is non-contagious and
you know just delay it like a lot of
americans think that's a good idea
um i i do not know how this is going to
play out but uh you know
it's uh the the none of this is good for
trump
um because they need a game changer and
all of the game changers are getting are
negative
you know it's a negative game changer
again
uh yeah so so that that's where that
that's like the
way i'd frame the vp debate is that you
if you're looking for a game changer
uh there wasn't one yeah um
i agree i thought i mean it's kind of
boring um in some ways
um which some have told me like that's
what
uh presidential debates used to always
be um so maybe we you know
we're accustomed to crazy political
theater now um
well there was an important element of
it too where like
i i thought pence was a con convincing
messenger for another version of
uh reality uh because he had like a
measured manner that made it seem like
everything he was saying
is um reasonable uh even if
some of it you know it was less so and
and so i think that is what we're used
to from these debates but there's a
quote
that um i thought was really important
um because uh
it spoke to a lot of people and this is
from a
politico article from the last couple of
days it said
quote america has entered a kind of
postmodern political era
where the appearance of governing is
just as politically powerful as actual
governing
because most people most americans now
live in partisan spin bubbles that
insulate them from the facts on the
ground
uh and so at this point you have
uh the parties presenting their own
versions of reality and then we just
argue it's like
hey i think that version of reality is
real no i think this version of reality
is real
uh and that's disastrous you know it's
like
you have to have some objective reality
that we can all look at and say yeah
you know you did a terrible job you did
a great job
instead of just being like no uh you
know i did a great job
and then it's gonna get worse and worse
because
you have the partisanship um shooting up
because of the fact that people are
getting news from different sources and
social media which we're going to talk
about with tristan
harris a little bit later um uh on
and then you have the eventual
proliferation of deep fakes which
is going to make versions of reality all
the more
um individual and powerful so
the the fact that we have people
debating and not
actually confronting facts it's like the
moderator
almost should be able to lay down the
law and be like here's some facts like
plea you know it's like
like do not or whatever yeah don't
dispute them it's like this is to have
like a
factual convo um and right now that's
you know not it's a very tall order for
any moderator
um because like uh
pence and and kamala if you're a pro you
just really just go
towards whatever version of reality
you're trying to present
yeah so that was actually what i wanted
to ask you i thought it'd be interesting
so
and it relates to what you're talking
about with tristan harris who's our
guest on the show today
the bubble effect of these debates so i
i try to i follow a lot of conservative
accounts and then of course a whole
bunch of
liberal accounts to try to get the
perspectives and that that gives me some
extremes i don't love it but it's the
best i
try to do um the liberals are saying
kamala dominated
um they said that pence was mansplaining
and that you know they love the excuse
me i'm speaking line um
and i do think objectively she she hit
him pretty hard on kovid i thought she
had some really good points there from
me
um but the conservatives say that pence
dominated and like
kamala you're entitled to your own
opinion but not untitled your own facts
um he was cool calm collected he spun
trump he was a better spinner than trump
in his own way um
and and i thought from my opinion i
thought pence was good he was i didn't
love what he had to say but i thought he
was a very good debater and
it reminds me of like i don't remember
if you remember i don't know if you
remember
mitt romney saying um i had binders full
of women
and he meant binders for women
applicants for you know various
positions in his companies
and the republicans thought this was
like no big deal and democrats like this
is outrageous what an idiot
and it's like you watch this thing and
you you take what you want
to based on what you're rooting for and
so my question for you andrew is this
like political fandom where you're like
i'm a jets fan
so no matter who they're if they're
playing the patriots i'll always hate
the patriots and
no matter what information goes the
other way or
is it because you're in the social media
bubble like is it both like what do you
i feel like both sides thought they won
and that probably can't be true i don't
know what you think but it feels like
fandom to me
the the evaluation of who won a debate
is um purely subjective
so you know if if you lined up millions
of americans and they all say one person
one the person won
you can't be like well all those people
are wrong
you know um it's one reason why they
show the poll after
um but to your point
uh there's something very um
pervasive going on where
political parties and candidates have
their own
codes and moral symbols and language
and you could do something that would be
incredibly offensive to one camp that
another
camp would find totally benign
uh and that's gotten worse
uh you know the the book the righteous
mind that also is tied to what
um tristan talks about in his work we
talked about this a bit with
matt jones last week where
conservatives speak along a different
set of moral values
which include sanctity loyalty and
authority at a higher level
than um the left liberals and
progressives
so if you say something that suggests
like particular
hierarchical arrangement conservatives
would be like sure
whatever and then liberals
will will be like oh that's really
object like offensive you know i'm mad
about it
uh so uh you know so like i
i think that's going to be something we
continuously struggle with
um because that polarization is getting
stronger
yep so we're starting to get more and
more passionate about
democracy reform this is my idea andrew
i think we change the debate format
um and we need to we may want a lobby
that is what is it's called the
nonpartisan commission on presidential
debates whatever the hell it's called um
it seems to me the goal of the debates
should be to educate voters right um
like that seems to be the only goal like
who's running and what do they stand for
and where are they on the issues
so to me this like two minute sizzle
reel reality tv show back and forth
theater is actually a disaster for that
so i this is my idea i think you do you
put it on tv but you do long-form
podcast
style where it's sitting down two
microphones and i think you do it on
topic you say okay we get
this one's on the economy in healthcare
today the only two things we're talking
about you just go go and it's long form
there's no
like you even if there's interrupting
you have a longer period for stuff to
breathe so you actually have to have the
convo
and then i think another fun twist would
be
letting the candidates or the parties
pick the topics because i think you
would be interesting
and educational for topics that no one
likes touching like
abortion or roe v wade or immigration or
um you know things that various aspects
of human rights and justice and george
floyd and things like that
i think would be fascinating to actually
force the candidates to take
that position publicly in long form
um and i think you'd see a lot of
changing across parties that's my
thought that's my idea
what do you think i love the idea of
trying to change up the format
um and do things that are more
asynchronous and innovative
there's an idea that i just
got from lawrence lessig around
something called deliberative
polling um so here's lawrence lessig's
argument he says look
right now if a pollster calls you up and
says what do you think about foreign
policy what do you think about
um about gun safety laws or whatnot it's
like we
all say something but sometimes
we don't really know that much about an
issue but we're just gonna
throw down and you know express our
opinion because that that's just you
know like
how polling works and his argument is
like look we're not experts on any of
this stuff
uh and we don't have that much
information and the average american is
not exactly like researching foreign
policy and you know on the daily
uh and so his argument was that you do
is you
uh bring together a group of people like
the network's trying to do with these
undecided swing voters
um you you bring together a group of
people that are representative of the us
population
but then you actually give them a lot of
time and information about a particular
topic
where they get points of view they get
both sides they get a
you know like and then they come out
with like a judgment and oftentimes that
judgment is very very consistent with
what
most of us would want because there is
like a sense of common sense
that a lot of these deliberative polling
bodies can generate
um the the problem with the these the
current format right now is you're
essentially rewarding performers
uh and then afterwards we're like ooh i
like that performer i think that
performer did great
you know and better performer destroyed
the other performer
yeah like uh that performer is so much
better and and like that
like there's something very um
noxious about it in a way it is
very american in the sense that like i
think uh you know america
likes folks getting out and uh
kind of like a two people in or one
person leaves
i love that yeah we're into that stuff
but uh
but if the purpose is to educate people
then it's tough because
you know you'd actually go about it
differently uh but i think some kind of
asynchronous
long form let things breathe like uh
and changing up the format where it's
not just
um competing two-minute sound bites
because you're dealing with people who
are
going to become optimized for that and
like i i experienced that you know first
time i showed up i was like all right i
guess we're going to talk about some
stuff and then
like after one debate was like okay i
guess
now we're we're going to um talk in 60
to 90 second modules and
you know it's like have you because you
could see with um
come along mike because they're both uh
i don't know mike pence at all but like
that that we're that they're
professionals and you saw them pivot
to the they knew what they were doing
both of them complete pros
and it was i mean it was well done like
i admired it i admired the craft but
if you have people who are good
at that then your learnings are limited
so i have two thoughts one was uh when
you talk about polling like we
the polls on universal basic income like
whether or not you like it or not if you
take the word government
out or put it back in like it changes
drastically right
do you like cash payments to help people
work in america be like yes do you like
cash payments for the government you're
like no
um or various versions of that um so i
agree with you
um there's a probably way to fix it
polling and then this is gonna sound it
might be unamerican to say this
in you in its own you know traditional
sense but we probably need to take the
excitement and fun
out of politics like we need to shorten
it up make it less sexy
like more boring because these problems
are long and complicated there the
problems are not sexy and fun
and we're putting these people out there
that are um
they're flashy you know and their job is
to be flashy and you said this a lot on
the trail you said
if i was a ceo doing what i'm doing
right now running a company i'd be the
worst ceo ever and you watch those ceos
flame out all the time because they're
all about themselves they're all about
the limelight and all about the like the
next hot thing and it doesn't
it's not affected the runner
organization yeah no we we should just
be like
if you're running for president again
you have a record in the rest of it like
i feel like every media organization
should just be playing the stats and
being like here's where it was when you
took over here's where it is now
like you know like how are we doing and
to just like have a have
like a but like what what are we
evaluating these people on like
the problem right now is we're
evaluating people on um
their performance ability the way they
make us feel
like uh you know the the way that the
media amplifies particular
um messages and you know i'll i'll be
the first to say it's like i'm more
amenable to certain
messages than others you know i think
like a lot of people are um
but no there's an objective reality that
is decomposing around us
you know like uh and like we have to
start holding our leaders
accountable to the objective reality
there there was that piece in
the new york times recently that said
you know america's 28th
in all of these major indicators like
access to clean water
and uh maternal um health and infant
mortality
uh and life expectancy you know it's
like america's
uh that'd be a slogan it's like america
like we're 28
you know like like some some of these
numbers uh are
um appalling uh and you can very clearly
see that we're
we've developed a political system where
those numbers can keep on backsliding
and then like each camp is like yeah
we're doing a great job you're terrible
and being like oh
you know there's a an author named
phillip howard that said something that
i
said on the trail he's like the parties
are playing you lose i lose you lose i
lose they're just passing the ball back
and forth
uh and meanwhile we're all losing like
that's that's really the danger
uh and you know i'm i'm on board with
like you know
uh like most all the democratic
uh like priorities and policies in terms
of
um trying to improve education and uh
i think we need medicare for all a
single-parent healthcare like
my policy prescriptions uh line up more
with the
current democratic party um but we're
we're we've devised a system that's
going to make it very hard for anyone to
govern and solve problems because that's
not really how we're evaluating people
we voted we being the united states of
america in 2016 voted for donald not
because of his business acumen he did
not run
i mean that was part of it but that was
not what like really got vetted in the
media it was his ability to message and
talk about stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
here at yankspeaks you know we think
your data should be yours
and not someone else's we're supporting
prop 24 in california if you're
listening to this
where we can have higher protections for
your data rights but in the meantime
if you're just doing your thing online
and you don't want
the tech companies and the data brokers
to get a hold of every click
every like every this and that you can
use expressvpn
which is something that the big
companies have their people use it's
like beaming into the internet
remotely using a server far away it's
like you're a spy
the spy doing whatever you do nothing
really you know
espionage but hey who knows maybe you
are
who the heck knows and if you were you
might use expressvpn too why not
it's the number one rated vpn according
to
cnet and wired people that know what
they're talking about
say this is it go to expressvpn.com
yang and you can get an extra three
months free on a one year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com
[Music]
the president still has coven as of now
thursday october 8th and recording this
there are 35 cases of covid
in the white house and growing um
the new diagnosis every day um and for
context
that is more new cases this week than
the entire country of taiwan
which has 23 million people and had
eight new cases um
so that that's what's happening in the
united states right now um now there's a
bunch of other countries some are not
good on testing but taiwan is um so that
data is is pretty accurate um
and there's information coming out of
the white house does rudy giuliani have
it no one knows how bad is trump no one
knows so it's actually tough to know if
that 35 number is
100 accurate um
this is my hot take get your [ __ ]
together like
yes on a human level we don't want you
to have covid but the real risk of covet
is how you spread it to others
right like that is the bigger problem um
and you've got other people in the orbit
getting it
well in case of the white house in
theory they're doing very important work
every day
and you know like yes i'm sure that that
organization's
much less productive now because
everyone's hiding from their boss you
might have covid and
that thing yes we need you to like i
need you to manage yeah like you know i
and i mean it's true for their campaign
too it's one reason why i think this is
going to end up
um being uh a landslide election frankly
uh is that you have a losing trump
campaign that's had their chief
messenger get kovid
and then your campaign manager has covet
2 so he's quarantining like the
entire team i'm sure is
limping around in terms of what they
would need to do
a few weeks before the election you're
now getting swamped on the airwaves
you know you're getting out spent i mean
like
aside from the fact that trump has
pulled um
away from some incredible uh
uh like controversies and scrapes before
and we're like oh
like you know it's like a movie villain
where you're like
you know you can't be sure that he's
gone until like you know like he he's
like been like thrown off a cliff like
10 times or whatever it's like you know
what i mean like the movie really keeps
coming back like a terminator
uh donald trump's like the political
terminator
um for a lot of people but it but if you
look up
uh if you look up you gotta know it's
like look this thing's shaping up to be
a landslide
uh and if i'm the democrats uh i'm
investing in edge races where you're
like what's that you know
we traditionally lost that place by 10
points you might win it this time
[Laughter]
like you look at iowa right now holy
crap it's iowa it's texas it's south
carolina it's alaska
it's montana uh it just goes on and on
like you could
just maine i mean i think susan collins
is on track to lose and you know so like
that there's like a
um there is a massive opportunity um
we're we're
we're actually um uh i think still
kind of trying to shake off the trauma
of 2016 and every day since then where
everyone's like
you know oh no like you know you can't
be sure we're going to beat this guy
um i i think right now you know you have
to actually get greedy
and look around the map and say like
okay
um you know the and we just endorsed a
couple of candidates today
um john hodley and christy smith um who
are running for congress
in michigan in a very competitive part
of california you know i'm
actually surprised there are a lot of
freaking um
red parts of california like they have
very uphill climbs
um but given the
shape of this climate in 2020 do i think
that a lot of dems are going to win
in places that have not been friendly to
them heck yes like we should be freaking
piling in
uh you know like i mean the the wave is
coming
um and i i would have to say like this
wave has been
earned by the republicans it's like
they've really done
like a poor job of
governing over this last period of time
um and i think they're going to pay a
price
they've done a number man and look when
you run for office
there's a bunch of different options you
have for messaging right you the whole
but you but you pick your
your focus you pick your why and you go
with it when there's a pandemic
that message gets picked for you in my
opinion
you got one you know you got one when 9
11 happened
bush was not out there talking about
lowering taxes he was talking about
never forget we come together we support
our
first responders like we bring this
country together whether you're
republican or democrat you're american
um first and
the message for donald trump when the
pandemic happened was we come together
and we beat this thing he could have
kept make america great again like he
could have actually
framed this in a healthy way he didn't
he missed it
i don't think there's another option for
him he refuses to do it
um they they didn't even pass freaking
uh a relief bill i mean that
that is just mind-boggling it's like
let's see i'm the sitting president i've
got control over
uh one of the houses of congress every
american knows we should have a relief
bill every economy is saying like we
should have relief bill
and we can't get it done you know like
that that's like
you know i mean that stuff's
unfathomable you know like i tweeted
that it was [ __ ] terrible when he
announced it's like we're not doing this
until after the election it's like are
you
like yeah and i tweeted that on behalf
of the american people who are suffering
um but if you look at it objectively
like
it's donald trump i saw someone saying
like look this is him
essentially like uh committing political
suicide where
he's looking up being like and you know
i could take credit for bail people out
i could send people checks i could do
this thing
uh it would be both the right thing to
do and the politically wise thing to do
and democrats would get on board with it
because democrats are not some people
who'd be like
let's not do this even though we can all
see it and they're not doing it so
like this is the kind of misgovernance
that uh
you know get gets you uh out in your
year by
a wide margin ridiculous he said no and
then he tweeted yes and now he's saying
no
it's a hot mess and the market's going
to [ __ ] um the federal reserve jerome
powell literally the head of the federal
reserve said if we don't have a massive
stimulus
we're toast oh that's that's the problem
we go back and forth like talking hands
all day and [ __ ] about her you're fired
up
but the reality is millions are
suffering the reality is
your kids are gonna have a tough time
getting a job in this economy the
reality is
we have dark years ahead um so to your
point earlier
i think the dem should go for blood as
long as they're not like is still seeing
the ball into the glove in the states
they have to win
like if you could flip texas do it if
you can flip something like because
that's a
that's where the the change is needed in
the actual governing
two three years from now you know yeah i
so
the this um people don't like it when i
do this but
whatever um like i i think joe and calm
are gonna win
uh i think that they're but don't like
when you do that yeah i know i i don't
even like when you do that
no no one likes it but whatever i mean
whatever
like you don't do things for p you know
to please people you know your honest
guy
yeah you know i just say what i think uh
so the
um i think dems are going to get uh
a lot of gains um i think they're gonna
get the senate
um i think they're gonna control all
branches of the government and and
here's like the major major challenge
is that can we do enough so that we can
actually start to reconstitute
all of the broken trust and the
suffering
and make it so that it's not that okay
now we have the ball again
and things just continue to get worse
and everything is
continuing to disintegrate um and so
that
that to me is the real challenge at
stake i actually think this election
is is done um uh and you know like the
the question should be whether we win um
in places that that are not um
dem friendly and whether or not we like
what the size of the gains are frankly
but uh the real question is how do you
govern how do you actually solve
problems and republicans have a lot to
say about this too because you know you
can still
obstruct a lot as we've seen in other
other times
but we need like a new new deal
level reinvestment in the country and
done the right way so it's not like hey
we've created all these programs that
you maybe don't uh use or trust it's
like
like it's one reason i'm so passionate
about universal basic income or cash
relief
um is like if we get in there and be
like hey let's rebuild the country
and here's um like a lifeline for you
and your family
that's the kind of thing that would help
us
come back in a genuine way and get us
all invested
and possibly even unify us and bring us
together to a higher extent
that's the great hope and the great
challenge because we have not done a
great job
at this for years it's why so many
people are so pissed off and disaffected
um uh and like the the thing that people
have said
over and over again and you know the
extent it was some extent it was
overstated they were like
don't worry about trump worry about what
comes after trump uh
it's that if if joe and kamala win and
the dems win
with like i believe uh we will um
like we have an opportunity a window
to govern and rebuild uh and we have to
max it out
um to have a chance uh because a lot of
the stuff that animated
uh donald trump is just getting stronger
frankly you know i mean like like what
what animated trump is
institutional distrust and dysfunction
uh and
that's shot up during this pandemic uh
you know
like mental health problems shot up uh
like the people um
adhering to conspiracy theories shot up
uh you know and again we're going to
talk
to tristan about this um so so the the
challenge that that's really to me
like i i've already seen the ball into
the glove in my mind zach and you're
like to the main i mean i'm gonna work
my ass off and like you know between now
and election day and like that the rest
of it
um but my mind's already on like okay
like let's say we we win like you know
what does the
challenge truly look like and can we
rise to the occasion
so i'll say this um two things one um
for those of you listen i i disagree
with you that um this is in the bag
and mainly not because your data and
your sense i think i fundament
fundamentally 100 agree with it's just
that to me
never count out donald trump and never
count out the conservatives i think
they're better
historically way better at this than the
democrats are
in terms of changing the game and
flipping the script and
um finding ways to win um i'd love to be
proven wrong and i will do everything to
to be proven wrong but i do i don't
think it's it's over yet but i i i agree
i understand your point um the second um
thing is where i talk about is you and i
are very very aligned which is
right now you myself
our organization our networks we are
doing what we can everything we can to
help joe
and kamala win because that's that is
the first step to solving these problems
right
um but after the election is going to be
when we get back
to the problem solving piece whether
that's in the administration or outside
um and that's where i think the real
work is because
to your point if joe and kamala get in
office and we have same old same old
it's it's i think trump has just tipped
the iceberg in terms of how bad it can
get
you know um yes i think that's kind of
what you're saying so
folks vote look at me i voted you can
see this
i went and i got a mail-in ballot it's
very safe it's got my name on it
fantastic um our name on the envelope
not the actual ballot because that's
private but i just showed it to you
um but please vote that's how we
actually win when you guys get out there
and vote convince your friends to vote
um
vote any way you can they're all legit
don't buy the the fake narrative we are
good at
generally good particularly mail-in
voting in this country um
so please vote um all right let's um
andrew let's introduce tristan man this
is gonna be uh
this conversation this is the topic this
is it
yeah uh you you know him i hope you know
him so okay
uh if you have not seen the netflix
documentary the social dilemma
please do see it watch it um watch it
tristan harris is uh one of the main
reasons that documentary exists you've
hopefully heard of him
he's a design ethicist at google after
he
wrote an impassioned message about how
what they're doing there
like touches uh millions and billions of
people and they're not actually
uh struggling with like what their
design choices will mean
and then he's taken that work to social
media
platforms the the choices that we're
making there
the fact it's corroding our democracy
our mental health
um so he started an organization called
time uh time well spent
uh to talk about how we can use
technology better and the center for
humane technology
uh i said on the trail all the time that
we need a new department of the
attention economy and i'm going to ask
tristan to head it
because tristan's one of the foremost
thinkers
about what technology is doing to us and
our minds
um he i also quoted him on the trail all
the time when when
he said that we have some of the
smartest people in the country turning
super computers into
slot machines and dopamine delivery
devices for uh
us and and our kids uh and he's spot on
about everything
uh he's such an important figure um
the world would be a darker place if we
didn't have someone like tristan
fighting for humanity
i'm thrilled to have him on yeah he is a
source of light
and knowledge um please do watch the
document i'll probably talk about
you know over and over again but social
dilemma tristan harris
the founder of the center for humane
technology
andrew did you see facebook's response
to the documentary
i did not what do they say i'm gonna
send you this [ __ ]
it's it's so bad oh
it's like they have like seven reasons
why the social dilemma is [ __ ] and
the first one's like addiction
like facebook builds a product to create
value not to be addictive
two you are not the product facebook is
funded by advertising
so that it remains free for the people
what the [ __ ] it's
outrageous this thing is so my skin
crawled because i don't think how you
could watch a soldier's dilemma and then
hear facebook's response like facebook's
appropriate response like hey
like the goal phase would do this we've
got a little way from it we're getting
better right
like that to me would have been a better
response this is like a straight-up
denial
but yeah we tristan harris is the only
i mean frankly he yang you talked about
this on the trail but he brought this
with the the documentary he's been
working on he brought this to light he's
like picking up the rock when all the
bugs are
scattering like it's he is
this documentary should have ripple
effects for the tide is the tightest
turning if you will in dc
in public opinion um and he's a
he's a saint for doing it frankly
because i don't think it's necessarily
monetary helpful or helpful his career i
think he becomes a bad guy in a lot of
ways so
um pumped to have him tristan harris
[Music]
all right holiday season is around the
corner which means given that maybe
you're not visiting everyone that you'd
like to visit you might be mailing them
stuff
before you might go to the post office
but now you really should check out
stamps.com we use stamps.com
all the time on the campaign it's like
having a post office on your computer
and now it includes ups
so it's like usps and ups all-in-one
on your computer you can print
everything you need just stick it on the
box
no need to wait in line it is glorious
and there's no risk with my promo code
yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
the scale is not that big you can't
weigh yourself but you can weigh
packages
and that's really all the scales for so
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in yang
that stamps.com enter yang so i just
voted
and in order to like a mail-in vote in
order to do a mail-in vote you actually
have to provide your own stamp
so just use stamps.com to get my stamp
so uh if you're voting you may want this
because i don't know how many of you
have stamps lying around your house or
apartment or wherever you are
so stamps.com stamps.com enabling
democracy since 2020.
[Music]
it is my pleasure and thrilled to
welcome to yang speaks
someone i consider a friend but more
than that he's a hero of mine in terms
of explaining to folks how technology
uh is hurting us as well as helping us
tristan harris welcome to yank speaks
tristan
andrew thank you so much for having me
it's great to see you again um
i really keep singing your praises for a
minute tristan i want to keep singing
your praises hi god
design ethicist founder of the center
for humane technology
you might have seen him in what in my
mind was a groundbreaking and
award-winning documentary
uh the social dilemma that's on netflix
one of the most human people on earth
all right sorry i'm going to do your
introduction justice
it's really great to be here andrew i
i've always tell people hopefully you'll
mention how we met
but um you know it's been just amazing
to see
your really authentic rise from
you know what what i thought were humble
beginnings when we first met at the ted
conference in 2017 and i'm just blown
away by what you've been able to
accomplish
um and anyway we'll get into all of it
but i'm just just as happy to be here
with you
thank you uh you and i met
several times uh over the last number of
years
there was ted uh and then there was
uh an event in new york where arianna
huffington was there
and uh uh we reconnected and then there
was a house party
in the bay area where
i was like hey it's just out of the
kitchen and they're like uh
um so it certainly felt like we were
going to be working together
in various ways and there are so few
people
who really there's only one of you um
and i want
um for people who don't know you that
well and i know you must be a little bit
tired of relating your background and
how you came to
to this uh this cause this organization
uh but you became kind of a like a
singular
a voice of reason in silicon valley a
number of years ago when you worked at
google
yeah i mean uh so my background for
those who don't know
um i actually just to tell a slightly
different story that i think relates to
your experience i used to be into tech
entrepreneurship
i had a small startup company i was ceo
of that company was called apture
uh it was sort of a failure after five
years it got talent acquired by google
um but i i know the startup game i know
the
thing that people who are building
engaging attention-driven applications
face
when when you're an entrepreneur and my
friends in college
you know i studied computer science at
stanford and was part of a lab called
the stanford persuasive technology lab
i studied there with the founders of
instagram especially mike krieger
who and i who i was project partners
with actually
and we originally were thinking of how
we could apply persuasive technology for
good uh which is
you know we had this professor bj fogg
who would teach
you know how do we apply the principles
of persuasion to
technology and could we use it to help
people live their dreams live their
goals so work out more floss more
whatever it would be
and mike and i the founder of instagram
built something called send the sunshine
which was the idea that if you knew two
phones and you knew one of them was in a
zip code
that based on the weather forecast had
five days in a row of bad weather
the other phone was in a good zip code
with good weather it would
send a text message to the person with
good weather to say hey your friend
traston has bad weather do you want to
send him some sunshine
so this was using persuasive technology
to orchestrate more
i don't know love or compassion or
kindness for other people
and so we saw those tools but then
overall as things progressed i saw how
more and more of
my really well-intentioned friends got
trapped in this kind of venture
capital-driven
viral growth get maximum engagement
maximum time spent
and it become became as the phrase now
is known the race to the bottom of the
brain stem the race into the lizard
brain
to try to to get people using their
products and it was through seeing that
and being at google
that i sort of said something's wrong
here and i have to say first that google
is generous and i think
creating a space for me to do some of
that research where i became a design
ethicist thinking about how do you
ethically steer and design people's
attention when you're playing with some
very deep-seated psychological
vulnerabilities
so you mean they didn't exactly hire you
to be a design ethicist
that's right yeah i arrived that through
as sort of the secondary
success of this presentation that was
sounding the alarm about
how we were really kind of like the
stewards the moral stewards of
the human collective consciousness that
two billion people's minds are running
through the kind of wiring diagram of
how we
create the attention economy you know
through our choices like what how does a
notification work how does a news feed
work
how do app store payouts work do you get
paid the more you
you know send you know teenagers to
hospitals for depression or do you get
paid
based on you know subscription revenue
based on people feeling that they're
getting value from something
so all of those mechanics were you know
really part of how
google was positioned to try to be a
federal reserve of the attention economy
or kind of a government of the attention
economy
but the critiques were obviously much
larger than google it was really about
how
how does this entire tech ecosystem work
in the best interests of people which is
why i think it relates
very much to your work like how do we
make this these systems these economic
systems really work for people
yeah i feel like you and i are tackling
uh related problems
of humanity that we are facing right now
in 2020
i want to rewind a little bit further
back just because i find you to be such
a fascinating figure you grew up
in um the bay area to a single mom is
that right
yeah yeah um grew up in san francisco
and went to a small
school for for working parents i grew up
just with my mother not not with father
and then we went and moved up to santa
rosa to the countryside to live out
her dream of owning horses and um i had
no one in my family was interested in
technology i was the only one who
was always on the computer and learning
programming when i was about 15 and um
you know didn't anticipate anything that
would be happening now certainly
so you're the the geeky kid who's on the
computer
you get into stanford which is not that
far away so i'm sure
uh you know you're excited about it you
get there
and it sounds like you were working on
technologies to try and do something
positive that
bj fog persuasive technology is uh class
now legendary because it seems like half
of the major
uh tech entrepreneurs of the the last
generation all went through there
how was your time at stanford and did
people have a sense even then
of uh the magnitude of both the changes
and the companies that would
spring from it you know when i was there
so i was there from 2002 to 2006
um and you know i should say
i was including with the founders of
instagram and several other of my
friends who were
you know really optimistic we used to
meet and wonder like what would be the
ways that we would apply
you know our computer science degrees
towards social impact um that's actually
we used to gather every
three weeks or so and sit in some hidden
part of the stanford campus and
brainstorm you know what
what those projects might look like we
supported each other
we all had really positive intentions
you know this is different i didn't know
the people who started facebook although
i remember when facebook
landed on the stanford campus when i was
a sophomore in 2004
and we saw you know the kind of arrival
of photo tagging
and the way that it sort of took over
stanford dorm room life and that's
actually what you see in the film the
social dilemma
is um you know the how the features of
photo tagging which was this perfect
sort of persuasive cocktail
to keep people coming back to facebook
at that time because it's basically
tapping into
you know one of the most ancient kind of
um
deep-seated human vulnerabilities which
is social approval hey there's a photo
it's of you and someone else tagged you
in this photo don't you want to see
obviously there's a good photo or not
and when they found that that feature
and it worked it's like let's dial that
up like crazy and have everybody
uploading photos and tagging each other
all day long and i'm sure the
productivity of the entire stanford
class
dropped by you know 20 or something like
that
um you know we didn't really know
obviously back then any of this would
lead to political polarization or mental
health problems for kids or
you know shred apart you know the fabric
of our you know information ecology and
people believing in more conspiracies
these came about much later i think
through people realizing where those
incentives of
uh maximizing engagement and attention
would take us
well you certainly had very positive
intentions because of the nature of the
company
you you founded out of stanford apgar
and
you were grinding away at that um so it
seems like we may have something in
common where i started a company
that did not work out i feel like
like your company came a lot closer to
get to working out and that
certainly no one bought my little
company uh to employ us in the way that
google
upon your company so can you tell us a
little bit more about your
entrepreneurial uh arc with
aptur because as someone who started a
company myself
it was very very hard um it sounds like
you had
some ups and downs too yeah absolutely
and it's funny i don't talk about this
that much
um so app sure just so i explained what
it was
the phrase we came up with it's it's
like lighter fluid for sparks of
curiosity
uh it was a a service that um
when a publisher like the economist or
new york times put it on their website
it would create this ability for a
reader to get on the fly multimedia
explanations about any topic
first started out as a publisher tool so
we had like the climate change blog on
the new york times and
several other sites basically linking
statistics or videos so you would say
hey i want to
so how how many of you were there and
did you like uh get a little bit of
funding out of stanford like when you
decided to launch this thing
yeah well i mean i was 22 i think when
we started the company and i
actually was living in argentina
learning to dance tango and on the
evenings working on this startup from my
from a cafe
um uh but i yeah i mean we
we had a few stanford friends of mine
and senior year get together we raised
venture capital um from um actually we
raised angel investing
for angel invest investing money from a
couple
fathers and friends of of some other
friends of mine from stanford
and we got our first deal with the
washington post this is back in the
heyday of people
asking what would the future of news and
online context be
and the idea was could we do something
really different and radically new when
it came to news online in fact
it was about social impact like for
example could you see
the congressional voting record of every
single politician while you were reading
the new york times and see the video
that they gave
of the speech that they gave on the
house or senate floor
right there in the article without
leaving the page and we actually built
that so on the washington post for
a few years in 2007 2008 you could click
on any
congress member and then see their
voting record and videos of them on the
house or senate floor
without even leaving that article so we
were really trying to create a kind of
transparency and positive social impact
and a reifying of what would make
democracy stronger
of course and this is where the story
turns what what happened
was that publishers like the economist
or new york times or washington post
would ask us okay
we thought we wanted you to help you
know give people these interesting
features to learn about whatever they
want
it ultimately our success metric for
them was did we increase
the amount of time people spent on their
website and that's when it really hit me
that my personal goal which is more of a
social impact almost
aesthetic or art driven goal of can we
make
you know democracy stronger give people
better information
was really a different thing than the
business goal which is about
maximizing engagement and attention even
on news websites
and the fact that i couldn't reconcile
that in my own mind that every day
i would kind of tell one story to our
team of engineers we were only about a
10 person company
um you know we would tell one story to
them of we're trying to make
the world you know more curious and help
people learn about things
but then there would be this other side
of it which was measuring our success on
how much time we were getting people to
spend
and i tried to pretend for a long time
that was the same thing
you know just like at facebook like
we're making the world more open and
connected yes we are doing that
but we're also maximizing just
engagement and they seem really aligned
right if one is happening like i'm
making the world more open and connected
then the other things should be
happening people are spending more time
so it's easy to fool yourself into
thinking that they're the same thing
and you know i don't think i've actually
told this this story before but
it was through um a set of other tech
founders and i gathering for something
we call
doubt club that i decided to basically
cave in and just
frankly you know let google acquire the
company for parts
um because you know it was hard to admit
to myself
that really we weren't going to go
anywhere and that this was
this was something that we were going to
be trapped in this attention game
forever
and there'd be a limit to the kind of
growth that we could get because we had
to fight for every publisher that
that um that used our our service on
their website
so we started a group called doubt club
where several founders you know
realizing that when you're a tech
founder
you can't really express you know doubt
this is a very isolating thing
being a founder because you're there and
it's like you're telling your team
hey we we're going around the corner and
tell the investors hey we're going
around the corner
like there's no one but like there's no
founder that's going to be like hey guys
i actually have my
doubts about this because one of the
things that happens is that any doubt
you have gets amplified and magnified
tenfold for
like anyone around you i'll tell you
running for president was like that too
it's like
you know like if the candidate starts
updating doubts people be like
wait a minute i'm dedicating my career
to like trying to get this person
elected what
you know so like you have to be freaking
stoic and on top of it at all times
completely right i mean and that's
that's the pressure as you're talking
about i mean
in many leadership roles you know
there's no safe place to sort of say
man i'm not sure if this is really the
right path or
maybe this business model is maybe we
shouldn't exist even you know
can you even think those thoughts or are
those thoughts unaffordable to you so
this group was really profound we we had
several friends and the first rule about
doubt club is don't talk about doubt
club because
definitely don't talk about that yeah i
mean we had to be
many many many of us we knew each
other's investors and so
if you're grieving a safe space to talk
about maybe this shouldn't exist
you know you're not going to go off and
you're going to keep that secret
obviously so
it was through that social support
though that several of us ended up
letting our companies become
talent acquired and what i mean by that
really is acquired for for parts i mean
this was not a successful acquisition
and then another person in that group
ended up just shutting down their
organization
uh and company but again i think what it
really had
us recognize recognizes the internal
conflicts and the kind of denial that we
can face when we're
sitting on top of something you've
raised millions of dollars you've got
12 people working for you've got
livelihoods that depend on you
can you be really honest about when
maybe the thing that got you here
isn't what is really still happening
that that social purpose
and um and that's when you know i think
this started to turn for me and i think
that's what's
at the root of when i look at many
people in the tech industry i don't see
them as evil people i see them as
trapped by a set of incentives that i
think now many of them also
agree are true um and this is just kind
of the place we find ourselves
yeah you experience the incentives
directly on two levels uh with aperture
number one is
uh how does my company grow and get paid
um
and that's related to how publishers
grow and get paid and that's
time spent on their website so they can
sell more advertising
and then the the second set of
incentives is um
if i'm in a leadership role in this
organization then
uh what are my imperatives what am i
allowed to express and not express
and those two things are playing out at
a gargantuan almost unthinkable scale
at a place like facebook because for
them instead of being like hey i'm going
to get an extra contract from a
publisher it's like i'm going to get
tens of billions of dollars
if we just keep this thing going and
then
if you're a senior executive at facebook
you're like okay i've got the biggest
franchise in the history of the world
oh some people are telling me maybe i
should examine my practices well let's
see
i have very very powerful incentives
like pulling me this way
and not really that way so you lived it
and i think you understand it more
deeply as a result
well i think that's actually why andrew
i think our our message
um i want to name there's many more
researchers in the community
uh who've been studying some of these
problems whether it's doug rushkoff or
sophia nobel
or others who focus on different aspects
of these harms
and we're really build on building on
the work of those people but i think the
reason that
when when our message came around that
it really resonated with people
inside the tech industry is it spoken in
the vocabulary and language that they
actually operate in which is
do you have a metrics dashboard do you
measure daus daily active users do you
use
do you measure maus do you measure
engagement time time spent
seven day actives we know the common
metrics and design decisions and the
kind of vocabulary
that people on the inside use so i think
when we spoke
it was the first time that i think
people on the inside had to come to
terms with
the fundamental misalignment of
incentives that i think people didn't
want to look at and i just want to name
that because
you know while i think we've been
successful at that we're building much
on the insights of people who came
before and have been
seeking these these areas whether it's
sherry turkle or you know more recently
uh jeanne tuenge and
jonathan height there's there's lots of
great people who are doing the research
and they're also in the film
um but i think we've been successful
because we've been speaking a language
that makes it more universally
understood
for the masses and that's why the film
actually is so exciting because i think
having it received in 190 countries and
in 30 languages
you know being number one in india
number one in lebanon recently
breaking records on for documentaries on
netflix i think it's created a
cultural moment a global cultural
awakening
akin to something like inconvenient
truth or a silent spring but for the
toxic business models of
some of the tech companies it's so
important i am so
proud of you and whoever
busted their tails trying to get that
movie into the world and netflix for
taking it up and distributing it thank
you netflix
[Music]
so i messed up my shoulder because i'm
learning i'm learning how to golf and
i'm horrible at it the angle i sleep at
at the moment is very very important and
i'll put it this way my old mattress
would have been a disaster
but my new one has been wonderful and
that's because my new mattress
is from helix sleep how helix sleep
works guys is you go online we basically
felt a survey on how you sleep and then
they match you with the mattress
um and they ship it to you in a couple
days um and it comes in this
very tightly wrapped box easy to get
into your home and bang pops open
next thing you know you have one of
those comfortable matches you've ever
slept on the other thing is you have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
before you buy it in the first 100
nights so if you don't like it
you're good you can get off it we've got
something good for yank speaks listeners
helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows as well to our
listeners at helixsleep.com
yang that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep
dot com slash and you get 200 bucks off
your first mattress
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2019 and 2020 according to gq
and wired magazine so can you imagine
doing that article
you just freaking just sleep on a bunch
of mattresses and say the best one
helix sleep
[Music]
so so you have this tough series of
meetings at doubt club and you say look
i think aptr
is not going to uh to stand the test of
time or grow the way i wanted to
um so then to get yourself aqua hired
for parts
uh by google is that like an easy thing
because
you know you're a hyper talented guy i'm
sure some of your engineers are
hypertown does it like
pick up the phone do you have video
friends at google we were like hey like
let's get this conversation going how
does that work
yeah it's an interesting um question um
i didn't i had some friends who were at
google but i didn't know any of the
leadership there
um certainly i think we were you know
what it was actually i could tell you
the story
um there was you remember when cora
first launched
yeah yeah and so adam deangelo who is
the cto of cora
had um started this question and answer
site which everybody now knows is called
cora
and there is the early community of cora
adopters and
one of the first questions that i think
i think it was zuckerberg who asked the
question on quora and it said
who are the most sorry i'm not trying to
toot my own horn here i'm just trying to
please go ahead what happened but um
zuckerberg had posted who's the
what are the most talented companies and
people that in silicon valley right now
that most people don't appreciate
and there's obviously lots of list you
know questions and sorry lots of answers
to that post
but the one that people voted up the
most was actually apture um
and and our team and so i think that
post where we were highlighted as a
uniquely
talented group of people led to some
conversations about acquisitions with
google i
came to know sundar pichai who at the
time was
he's obviously now ceo of google but at
the time he was
head of chrome and apps and um you know
we started an acquisition process with
a small competition it was very
challenging i mean actually you know
these things take a long time and it was
uh
really one of the most stressful and
depressing periods of my life to be
honest because
you have to admit that you know you've
been working for six years incredibly
hard and it's all just
you know you're gonna we got eaten up by
the borg i mean our entire service and
all the publishers and all the code and
all the data and everything we had done
got
you know you know became became ash once
we got acquired but
i think it did teach me some many
valuable lessons and i think it created
the foundation for the design ethics
work that took us to now
so you get absorbed by google they put
you on which team
was it gmail yeah they put us
on the chrome and apps team which then
so we started working on some advanced
like personal assistant type work um and
then that led to working with the gmail
team
uh and i started looking at i was
working with the people who were
designing the next version of gmail
and you know i found myself in the room
with you know the designers who manage
this interface where people i mean you
go to any internet cafe
back before covid and you see almost
every laptop has this like gmail
page open right i mean almost everywhere
oh yeah we all know it sure we all know
like
people live in this space it's a habitat
it's not just a product we use it's a
space we
we live and we work in and given that
importance i thought to myself you know
as we're designing the next version of
this this is an opportunity to really
think about
how this is an enormous source of stress
in people's lives you know
it's funny because i think one of the
responses to the film when i say
in the film that i'm really addicted to
my email a lot of people don't
understand that because email is sort of
just junk mail for for a lot of people
but coming from
i think the the generation that you came
from and that i came from email
is a central place where especially at
the time every now and then i would be
getting um
you know big introductions to people who
would help us advance the work
so it became my own slot machine to
check you know is did daniel kahneman
the head of you know the founder of
behavioral economics email me and
that kind of thing but that said we know
i was thinking about
uh is gmail really good for people
i was thinking about you know this is a
pretty addictive
stressful place in people's lives could
we reduce social expectations could you
make it so that when you send an email
you could say
hey i actually don't need a response for
two weeks could we start to implement
features that would reduce the
addictiveness
and you know there i am in the room and
there's no other room in the world
besides that gmail design team room and
if i thought at the room
where it happened and i thought if there
was any room where people would care
about this
this would be the one and i found
to no disparagement of my colleagues who
were working at the time i just didn't
find the conversation
really as thoughtful as it needed to be
given the consequences that we were
having for like six hours or four hours
of people's
days so first how many people were in
that room
that's a good question i think probably
somewhere between six to ten people
usually in those rooms okay how long
were you at google before
uh that this uh this discussion is
happening
um so within about three months we had
joined the gmail team and we're starting
to have those conversations so pretty
three to four months i was in there and
then you sent out a now legendary
deck around hey we should probably be
thinking more
deeply about the choices we're making
because they're about to influence
billions of people
over time was was that
just months after you joined google yeah
that was in
january of one year in so basically one
year into being at google after trying
to make it work with the gmail team
you know i really did i really wanted to
see us ship
something that would make a dramatic
positive impact on people's mental
health around
email and stress and notifications and
attention
and um because it wasn't going anywhere
and because
overall like other apps whether it was
quora or path or all that you know
instagram at the time which was just
you know blowing up um i was just
disappointed in where
are we as a tech industry heading like
what where have we lost our moral
compass do we really care
about what we're building and how it's
impacting people or have we kind of
forgotten um you know that there's more
to just capturing lots of attention and
going getting virality
and so i i started um i went on a trip
to the santa cruz mountains with my
um one of my best friends aza raskin who
um his father jeff raskin invented the
macintosh project at apple
and that's where we get our name um in
humane for the center for humane
technology
aza's father jeff wrote a classic book
called the humane interface which is the
foundation of some of our work
but aza and i were in the santa cruz
mountains and
you know connecting with nature and just
being out there and it just really
struck me that i needed to go back
and there needed to be something that
was said about this and it the words
came to me and that trip and it was
never before in history
have a handful of technology designers
who mostly look like
you know hipster engineers in san
francisco between 25
35 years old mostly men mostly white
you know making decisions on behalf of a
billion people was the number of the
time now it's three billion people
um to show you the growth rate of how
fast these things go
and the presentation included just a
bunch of examples you can actually find
it online on
minimizedistraction.com i think is where
someone had leaked it and posted it
but it used a bunch of examples of how
technology's
tapping into our psychological
vulnerabilities
and the cost that it was having on kids
on mental health
and it ended up going viral i sent it to
a few people
for feedback and instead of the 10
people i sent it to exclusively
i came to work the next day and i had
like 100 emails about it
so i knew it had gone viral to many more
people and
as the film the social dilemma says you
know it went up to larry page's office
in several different meetings that day
and i think it created a moment of
reckoning where we actually said hey can
we do something about this
and i would host follow on lunches at
google bringing people together from
different teams to talk about it
but it was just hard to get a real
coordinated action
because the external global pressure
from consumers or from the world or from
governments
just wasn't there and that's what's
astonishing is to see where it is now
because compared to you know lunchroom
meetings that i would book at a random
part of the google campus with
you know 12 people showing up saying how
do we fix this
to today where you have i think
something like 30 to 40 million people
are going to have seen this film very
soon
in 190 countries it feels like it's
taken eight years to get to a point
where we're gonna be able to
meaningfully change these incentives
so this is 2012 that you uh
send this deck out and then it goes
viral like google yeah
2012 to 2013 somewhere around there
beginning end of 2012
early 2013. all right let's call it uh
early 2013 then
um so when you send this deck out to
your 10 contacts
um were you concerned at all that this
is going to make you seem like
uh someone who is not on board with like
the
like the general direction of uh
development of
the project you're on i mean you're
relatively new to the company it's an
enormous company
and the rest of it like is there any
concern that this is gonna be bad for
your career
yeah um i'm glad you're bringing this up
because it's easy to skim past this now
i was i actually had no idea how people
were gonna respond i was prepared that
if i had gotten fired for some reason
because of it that i would be okay with
that so i i had pre-committed that that
was an okay thing an okay outcome for me
um and i was
you know i was actually really afraid to
send it out which is why it was
surprised
me when so many people um when it shared
virally i mean you know on google
slides you can click on a presentation
it shows you in the top right hand
corner how many simultaneous
viewers there are and there was
something like 150 and then later that
day like 400 simultaneous viewers
you know in a 10 000 you know whatever
it was 20 000 person company back then
so uh i did not
expect to be i've never been in my life
a person who went against the grain who
was highly disagreeable who was
trying to challenge things i wasn't
outspoken it just struck me that
no one was sufficiently paying attention
to this and it was too important not to
um so then
it sounds like the feedback was by and
large quite positive so much so that
they actually give you this new title
and role saying you're going to be our
our new design ethicist you're going to
tell us what's what
um so how how was that transition enroll
and how long were you in that role yeah
so this is important i
there was a fellow at the google
creative lab in new york who had
actually helped co-write to make this
the story all circular he helped
co-write the first macintosh uh the
famous macintosh super bowl ad if you
remember the woman
running down the streets and throwing
the hammer and smashing the big brother
screen
he had co-written that advertisement
and he had seen this presentation at
google
and was really impressed by it we
connected on um
[Music]
this this book that had really shaped
him by neil postman called amusing
ourselves to death
which is really i think entirely
descriptive
of exactly everything that's going wrong
right now that
culture and our society would surrender
to the forces of technology
and technology would become would start
to subsume
culture and remake culture in its image
and that we would be caught in this kind
of race not for attention didn't express
it that way
but this race to make things amenable to
how technology would want to see and
shape the world metrics like
you know in this case he was talking
about sat scores and predictive
analytics for college admissions and
things like that
but he didn't at the time know about a
few years later we'd have tech companies
running by the metrics of
time spent and engagement and that book
i'm using ourselves to death
opens with this description that we were
all watching out for the year 1984
when the form of dystopia and tyranny in
the form of big brother
and the orwellian vision of dystopia
would come to you know subsume society
and then luckily it didn't come to pass
we
made it through 1984 and that didn't
happen but he says that there was always
this second vision of dystopia that was
the more subtle one that people don't
remember as much which is aldous
huxley's brave new world
where the tyranny is not of restricting
access to information or
censoring what you can or can't think
but instead
bludgeoning people with a sea of
irrelevance with so much narcissism and
egoism and passivity and informational
overwhelm that people wouldn't know
what's true and they'd be amusing
themselves to death
and this was the book that this fellow
at google
who offered to host me to work on this
problem
uh and i connected on and then i started
to become i didn't know what to call it
so we just said
let's call it design ethics and no one
had ever thought how do you ethically
design
along the social psychological
vulnerabilities of humanity
and it became more of a research project
for the first
two years and i tried changing various
things within google we tried talking to
the android team and changing things on
chrome and
how would we make smartphones work
differently and talk to the app store
teams about changing incentives
but um i couldn't get anywhere and so
about three years
later um i decided to leave and uh soon
after that i was on the sam harris
podcast where um
you and i i think both launched our
careers in a certain sense
and yeah harris thank you thanks to sam
that podcast was the kind of coming out
moment for this work
and chris anderson who runs ted emailed
me
a few days later which was i think only
three days before the ted conference
and said i need to get you to come to
ted to do a ted talk on what you just
shared on sam's podcast and um i was
actually about to fly to czech republic
with
my mother who was dying at the time and
this was the last time we were going to
take a trip
abroad and i decided to go but then cut
my trip short
go to ted had two days to prepare this
first ted talk on how technology
controls a billion minds
and that's where i met you um i remember
the moment it happened at the
you know the buffet table i think on
that friday um and
um yeah that was it's a long time ago
now
well i i did not know what the run-up
was too
you know for me i was just blown away by
your talk and was like this that was
incredible
that's like um so hearing like i didn't
know about sam and um
certainly not um uh you know you're
abbreviating your trip with your mom um
so when you decide to leave google
here's the thing
google famous for its food famous for
all this stuff
you're hanging out there you've got this
design ethicist job and you're like hey
android try and do something better hey
you know like everyone trying to do
something better and you realize you're
not making headway
i still feel like 99 of people would
have been like
just stay there forever do your thing
because you're in like corporate womb
like you know people
respect you uh you're still in the
mothership
um so it feels like a big decision to be
like all right this is not working it's
time for me to go particularly when
when you decided to leave um it didn't
seem like it was clear what the next
steps would be
you know it's so interesting and i
really appreciate you asking these
questions uh uh
it that's exactly right it did not at
all feel clear
you know leave and go do what like how
you're inside of the biggest
most influential company in the world um
that is probably one of the biggest
surface areas for
these problems showing up which is all
of android which actually has a majority
of smartphone users around the world in
the us
obviously it's more iphone skewed um why
in the world would you leave
that environment and obviously be paid i
think nicholas nassim tele
wrote the line that the three most
addictive things in the world are
cocaine
heroin and a monthly paycheck um it's
very hard to walk away from
you know monthly security uh job
security
and i i really didn't know how we would
ever change
um these problems i i remember
feeling deep anxiety about what it would
mean to leave and not
and live off my savings frankly and
figure out what how in the world what do
you do to sort of get
people to care about something in a
public stage um
and there was about a year and a half
after that
um where nothing happened um and it was
when
i think trump got elected and the
election took place and the conversation
started happening about
russian manipulation of the elections
and i had seen certain things like this
myself and had been part of
a community of researchers who'd been
tracking some of those manipulations
that i decided i had to jump in full
steam into
um into this problem even if i didn't
know how we would
i would get the you know get the
attention it deserved and the real brick
breakthrough there was the 60 minutes
piece
in um 2017 called the addiction code
with anderson cooper
and that was the first i think major
event where
insiders from the tech industry were
speaking out about it and that's what
led to sam harris and that's what
i think helped accelerate this
conversation it was roger mcnamee who
wrote the book zucked
and i did an interview he was actually
the person on bloomberg
hosting if you don't know roger mcnamee
wrote the book sucked he was
an early investor in facebook roger is
uh very very smart and i i admired that
book and his work
yeah and and he was an early mentor to
mark zuckerberg in the early days he
actually was brought in as the opening
chapter of the book zuk says to sort of
convince mark not to sell the company to
i think it was microsoft or yahoo and to
instead
that he had one of the biggest companies
in the world on his hands and so
anyway so roger felt very similarly but
he was sitting there on the sidelines
and hosting this show on bloomberg tv
and after 60 minutes i went on the show
and he called me afterwards and said do
you need a wingman
and we set out to try to figure out how
do we start this conversation and we
were at ted together trying to figure
out
can we build allies and honestly we had
almost no one listening or paying
attention uh people were not
really engaged and it's taken just so
long to get the kind of public
conversation to
to match it now yeah they're paying
attention now
so so there's sam harris
ted um i feel like there was a steady
drum beat
of news and awareness jaren lanier is
part of this i believe
absolutely
[Music]
but i will say that when you sent me a
message saying hey great news netflix
documentary social dilemma
like it was still like a pretty big um
surprise to me and i know these movies
take a while
so so how the heck did the resources
behind the social dilemma
uh come about i feel like there must be
some heroic filmmaker we owe a debt to
absolutely so i just want to say also i
was just a you know primary subject in
the film
um we didn't produce the film i'm not
making money from the film a lot of
people think
you know they accused this of i don't
even know trying to make money off of
talking about the problem and this
couldn't be farther from the truth
um uh uh but we
so so the film was in the works for
about three years starting in 2017 in
fact
many of the interviews that are of that
i'm in that that i they're of me in the
film
were recorded in early 2018 late 2017 i
think
so um you know and they bear relevance
to to now and i think it speaks to just
how consistently
these issues were going to appear in
society the filmmaker jeff warlowski
uh was actually at stanford during the
same years that i was there we were both
apple campus representatives believe it
or not and
uh he had made two award-winning climate
change films one called chasing ice
and another called chasing coral about
you know the disappearance of coral and
and
you know the glaciers up in uh the
northern parts of the world
and we saw this as kind of a climate
change of culture
piece uh he didn't really know about
these problems he'd been following
um you know some of my work uh having
risen up in 2017 and we started talking
about it we had met the producers uh
lori david and heather reisman who we
owe just incredible gratitude to
through actually through ariana
huffington so who we also owe incredible
gratitude to
and this film got off the ground um and
it took
like we said about three years for it to
come out till now
and you know it was really important for
us to have it come out before this
election because i think it's
possibly most consequential for our
democracy we talk about a lot of harms
mental health of kids
talk about addiction but i really think
it's the breakdown of our shared
information ecology
and our ability to trust in shared
sources of information
and to walk away from you know a debate
and see the same movie as opposed to
different movies
i think this is the most existential
aspect that the film
really gets at is our our shared reality
is being torn apart like a paper
shredder
into three billion narrower and narrower
auto program truman shows where they
are programmed to give us a more
affirmation that you're right the other
side is wrong and here's even more
evidence
of whatever you believe about
controversial polarizing topics
and when you do that and you you run
that psychology opt you know
i think of like an optometrist who puts
this pair of glasses on your eyes
and they put those glasses on us 10
years ago because we started looking out
through the glasses of facebook
to see what is the world what's really
going on out there and we've been
wearing these instead of far-sighted or
near-sighted glasses we've been wearing
these outrage sided glasses
for about 10 years now and again not
just facebook but
but the kind of twitter you know
outraged machine the youtube outrage
machine
and so we're 10 years into this deep
psychology experiment
that has become the new normal and we
don't so it's not just about let's fix
the platforms now let's also
what i hope the film does is kind of
rewind the clock
and say if imagine if you wore this
hypothetical outrage
colored glasses so you walk into your
kitchen and when wherever you look it
shows you something you could be
outraged at like your spouse
left the dishes
my coffee can my coffee can wasn't there
exactly your coffee can is not there
and it's not even in the place you
usually leave it the dishes are out it
shows you who left the dishes out
when you look on the refrigerator handle
you see that someone sneezed on it
because it
the glasses highlight the green you know
micro particles of germs or something
so imagine you were wearing outrage
colored glasses everywhere you looked
and imagine you were wearing those
glasses for 10 years how would you
feel and think and act and navigate in
the world
if that was the construction and basis
of your reality and that's exactly what
we've had with
i think these social media platforms
again no one at twitter
we both know jack you know i think
intended for any of this to happen
it's just that this became this business
model and once the companies go public
they're they're forced to be on this
treadmill of keeping growth going and
growth is directly connected to
time spent and engagement yeah jared
lanier when we talked he said well we
looked up and said
seems like advertising is like the best
best business model we could think of
but then
taken to a multi-billion dollar extreme
it ends up having
um very uh the negative incentives
attached because it's like okay now i
gotta gin up
engagement and how am i gonna jit up
engagement by making you outraged at
something
or afraid or um
eager to blame someone else uh so
i agree with the your description of the
problem the magnitude of it um
simultaneously to the this run-up
between 17 and
uh 2020 you also co-founded an
organization the center for humane
technology that's trying to
make people more mindful uh can you talk
a little bit about what the the center's
goals are yeah um so the center for
unity and there's also time well spent
you which i don't know which one you
want to
want to go into well yeah so the
original work
was um under the spotlight of a
of an advocacy group called time well
spent and the idea behind this was from
the
continuity of the first ted talk that i
that i gave in 2013 or something like
that
which was about the idea that we live in
a time spent economy that things are
competing for
your time and we obviously you can
always get more money but you can't get
more time so time is the finite resource
that we all share
and there's it's the ultimate neutral um
you know
flat leveling leveling playing field
that we all have to operate on
and if you have companies competing for
that you're going to end up with these
problems and we said the answer is
imagine a world where technology
competes to help us spend time well
and they're competing on the on the
basis of that finite resource
to direct it in the places that we would
say align with our own values
that work was important and became you
know the first stage of this
of all of this but it didn't capture the
the vast
like polarizing conspiracy theories
other kinds of effects that were really
at the heart of this and we needed
a new instantiation and frankly a real
funded
non-profit vehicle to do this work so
roger mcnamee
randy fernando andy sorry aza raskin
my co-founder co-founders of the center
for humane technology
put together this group and we actually
partnered with common sense media at the
beginning
and common sense media for those who
don't know is an advocacy organization
who focuses
on the issues of kids in screen time and
privacy related issues
and we really partnered up to do
advocacy in california
state legislature we did a conference in
dc called the truth about tech
conference
and we've done a bunch of media and
started making noise about these
problems
and since then you know the center is
really focused on realigning
technology's incentives with humanity's
best interests
simply put because the the fundamental
incentives of
um these large dominant platforms are
directly profiting from conspiracy
theories polarization breakdown of
mental health the more addicted your
kids are the more anxious they are
not that again anyone wants this to
happen the line in the film that i think
describes it best
that justin rosenstein says who invented
the like button
is so long as a whale is worth more dead
than alive
and a tree is worth more as lumber than
as a tree and we don't regulate
private forests or protect you know
state state forests
now we're the whale we're the tree we're
the the resource that is being strip
mined into our
you know our cognition and and that
means that we're worth more
if we're addicted distracted outraged
narcissistic attention-seeking polarized
and disinformed than if we're a thriving
citizen or a healthy growing child who's
you know living their lives in the way
that we want and i think this speaks to
some of your work andrew because it's
about dignity it's about are we the
product
where we're just a cog in the economy or
do we fundamentally have dignity
and can we have a system that treats
each of us with a kind of sacred dignity
that that it should work that way yeah
it's about do we work for the economy or
does the economy work for us
uh you know are we worth more outrage
than calm it's like well maybe i'd still
prefer to be calm even
above worth more uh outraged you know we
have to
see to it that we're not all just
instruments of
uh profit and revenue maximization
because it turns out
uh maximizing our
profitability is really bad for us it
means that we're
we're very very pissed off and ready to
uh click and act and
watch whatever videos you want to serve
to us at any moment in time
[Applause]
[Music]
one thing about this pandemic is trying
to feel good and take care of yourself
it's not easy
uh zakir wanted a health kick that
lasted about a month and then
uh he's been struggling ever since three
and a half weeks
but one thing that you can commit to
doing that
will help you feel better and be
healthier
is athletic greens over the course of my
life i have put a lot of
different mixes and shakes into my body
and athletic greens
uh truly makes a difference in a way
that the other ones have not
it you you imbibe it and it actually
feels
like you're helping yourself uh and the
science bears it out the nutrition bears
it out
it's like a super multi vitamin and if
you want
to boost your immune system feel like
you're treating your body well
in a way that's actually sustainable for
just about anyone
athletic greens is for you so make an
investment in your health today
try the ultimate all-in-one wellness
bundle support your immunity get health
and energy by visiting athletic
greens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d
for free with your first purchase in
case you're not getting enough sun
check it out athletic greens.com
[Music]
it's great to give people this sense of
what it took to get to this moment
uh the social dilemma the fact that now
in large part because of you
individually and all the people that
have helped
you and your work that the awareness
about the nature of these problems is
now higher than it's ever been
and if you look at polling around big
tech big tech has gone from can do no
wrong
to whoa like there are some real
problems and excesses that we're going
to have to figure out and get to the
bottom of
um you can see that with the recent
anti-trust hearings and the rest of it
which is one angle
um to me that's like fine um
but it's missing some of the fundamental
problems it's like you know
like pretending these tech companies are
you know oil companies or steel
companies whatever it's like not really
doing the trick
um so this is the the big um
the big thing i want to pick your brain
on so i'm so full disclosure
because this might entertain you people
would i would say things on the trail
like hey uh
quoting you i sometimes i attributed
sometimes i did and i knew you wouldn't
care
i would say we have some of the smartest
engineers in the country turning super
computers into dopamine delivery devices
for
our kids and it's having a disastrous
effect on our mental health
teenage girls in particular according to
jonathan hayden and eugene twenge's data
um
and then every parent in iowa new
hampshire
who heard this were like yeah because
that they see their kids getting
addicted to their screens and you know
it's not great for their development
and then they would turn to me and say
what are we to do about it and then i
would say you know what we're going to
do
and here's where i don't know if you
said this i said
as your president i'm going to start at
a pension detent
department of the attention economy and
i'm going to have my friend tristan
harris run it
just odd has been been trying to change
the design decisions of these tech
companies for years
now most of them you know just gave like
uh oh like you know andrew
knows someone specifically who who has
the right thinking on this
but if we were to play that scenario out
what do we need to do to try and
uh humanize our technology and our use
of it
first i just want to say a few things to
what you shared um
man yeah well i i just want to say i i
appreciate it so much that you
like with universal basic income and
like with other aspects of your platform
you i think have always prioritized a
kind of public education
in your work and trying to help people
understand and elevate issues that are
not being talked about and using your
presidential campaign to do that i think
that
was amazing you did that with ubi and
you've also been doing that with the
attention economy
and um you know i think you helped make
it even a bigger issue and i
just really want to say i really
appreciated that that you you led the
way
uh on elevating it as as i think to its
rightful position as one of the top
issues facing society because it's
underneath and exacerbating
all the other issues it makes it
impossible to solve any problems if we
can't even agree on reality
exactly exactly and that's what we say
in the film so clearly is if we can't
agree on reality we can't solve any
problem whether it's climate change
poverty or
social justice and racism or whatever we
want to we want to deal with so
truth be told this is not an easy thing
to regulate um
it has to do with core business models i
do think we can look
to ways that the climate movement thinks
about
an increasing overtime tax
to carbon you know to carbon externality
setting a price on carbon you know so
essentially
as we've talked about um this is an
extractive economy where instead of
extracting oil out of the ground and
then
producing you know climate change at a
global level
in the commons depleting the
environmental commons and also
eroding the the life support systems of
the planet that's the
fossil fuel economy in this case we have
an extractive economy
built on not just extracting human
attention but as we talked about in an
earlier interview we did
um fracking for human attention because
we're worth more also when we're
multitasking um it's
really quickly on that we're worth more
when you have a tablet a phone and your
television up and that triples the size
of the attention economy because now
you're paying attention to three things
so antarctic
but one one thing that very much like
that when you use the metaphor of
fracking for attention you start to see
that we're selling just like the
financial crisis
thinner and thinner slices of human
attention
as if it's worth the same as valuable
concentrated attention but it's kind of
junk attention just like
we're selling thinner and thinner credit
default swap type you know
junk instruments financial instruments
and selling it as if it's this bigger
thing
and propping up this kind of inflated
advertising attention market
um so i think one one thing we can do is
we can correct for that inflation
um and i think there's one study from a
couple years ago where facebook was
found to inflate
the amount of advertising reporting that
it did for
um their advertisers by 900 meaning they
exaggerated
how much the viewership or clicks there
was by 900
so that's just like you know a financial
broker exaggerating the value of
you know a financial instrument by a lot
so we can kind of
clean up um comprehensively this
systemically fragile
fragility creating system so much like
you wanna
you can't just say we're gonna get
completely off of oil in one year and
carbon
prices are gonna be set to a million
dollars a ton and
we're gonna move over you set up a
transition plan over 10 years
so i think what we need is a transition
plan from each company
maximizing how much attention that they
kind of extract
to winding down how much commodification
of human attention that we can do over
time
one model of this actually comes from
the way that we regulate energy
companies because it used to be that pg
e or con edison or whatever your energy
company is they're a
for-profit company uh theoretically they
want you to use as much energy as
possible so
leave the lights on leave the faucets on
maximize your just wasting of
energy and you're maximizing climate
pollution you know
activity and behavior they can even put
those nests in your home and then
maximize how much you use to like
manipulate you into using the most
that would be a kind of dystopian
reality our our recommended home
temperature
is 95 degrees
and get you to change it all the time
and you know um anyway
so obviously that would be an extractive
kind of business
and it's fundamentally misaligned with
the commons because it accelerates
climate change et cetera
so we've dealt with this problem before
we actually have regulated utilities
that um set seasonal targets for how
much money you can make
as a utility off of a certain amount of
energy so for example
if there's a seasonal availability of so
much energy it costs this much for this
lower tier usage and then if you're a
consumer and you use let's say beyond
that amount
because it's a hot summer they actually
double charge you for that next phase of
of energy that you're using except those
extra profits don't go into the
the coffers of pg e or con edison they
go into a public fund
uh that actually invests in the
renewable energy infrastructure that we
need
so that's a nice i don't know if you've
got that it's sort of a nice transition
plan
of oh like oh i caught that
i don't know how i explained these
things you probably know these things
better than i do frankly but no no no no
so no
so let me let me just try and walk
through this just for fun so let's say
you and i are getting together and we're
part of the department of detention
economy and we're like all right
hey facebook here's the deal um
we find you excessively extractive
terms of the amount of attention you're
getting from folks so
step number one stop exaggerating the
amount of time we actually spend on you
that's that's number one but number two
um for every bit of attention you get
beyond a certain period let's call it
like our uh four plus four
uh teenager like there's actually like
some negative social value associated
with that
um so we're going to have you
pay a penalty um and then use that
penalty then to fund
some alternatives let's call it like
little leagues
or whatever like we bought something
that
that would be like that
facebook type of counter measure
is that more or less accurate well
i also want to say this is a tiny part
of probably a more comprehensive way of
dealing with these problems but i think
um there's an there's a part of it which
is that we have to remove some of the
perverse
um incentives um yeah what you're saying
now
reminds me of something i said when i
went to the can
con whatever you say call it uh
pronounce it advertising festival
where um you know we were talking to the
advertisers that fund all this activity
and these mental health harms
and said um you know after there's a
mental health crisis from kids
and there's a loneliness crisis
someone's gonna ask the question who
paid for all of this to happen
and it's obviously these advertisers and
one of the things we proposed was
imagine you just simply cannot make
money from usage
between let's say midnight and six in
the morning if you're a tech company
that disincentivizes usage of um sort of
late night lonely use that sort of the
low willpower period
of of use now that's that's definitely i
don't know what you're talking about
tristan i have never
done any low willpower ted tech social
media use between those hours
[Laughter]
i think you you were the superhuman
willpower one among us
kidding we've all done it but it's but i
love that idea so much where you
cordoned off
a number of hours where you're like look
extracting attention in these hours is
not not a good thing
it's like treating a park you know those
trees some of the trees we extract and
we turn into lumber other trees we say
this is part of a national park and
they're for walking and exploring and
enjoying right
and it's like some of our attention can
be maybe you know part of a
a system that obviously wants to
commoditize it but that's another thing
is there's sort of a violation of
turning a live humanness and a live
human choice
into these dead slabs of human behavior
through behavior modification engines
right so we turn like a live
consciousness
into this sort of deadened consciousness
in which your behavior is more or less
predictable because we've
taken what could be a free choice and
turn it into an unconscious habit
which is a form of kind of like dead
lumber as to a tree what dead
you know human behavior is to a live
human being there's many different
aspects to this that i think we have to
correct i think what we need here is
overall something more
comprehensive just like with the
financial crisis if you asked me andrew
and said what's the
one law that we passed that's going to
fix all this i like your approach that
this is sort of an ongoing issue and
that we need a cabinet level
department of the attention economy to
uh to deal with these problems
well let's dig into the tool kit a
little bit more because i'm already
learning a ton from you
um so i i love seeing it as
something of a negative externality like
attention beyond a certain point where
you say look
like i was thinking beyond our x
um is probably not a great thing for you
i love your saying look
between midnight and six a.m probably
terrible for
for teenagers to be uh facebooking it up
or
or whatnot like what uh just throw a few
things out there
like that also belong somewhere in like
the consideration set or tool kit
yeah you know we're going to be
publishing um some more on this on our
website
soon i have some of it up here right now
but i think a more comprehensive
approach
is something like what we had for the
financial crisis where we had
a comprehensively risk creating system
and we needed comprehensive basel iii
reforms in europe or the dodd-frank kind
of reforms the united states
i know there's some problems with that
but that's thematically what we would
want to be going after
so we need protection for kids privacy
for people transparency for platforms
you can imagine
you get section 230 protections for
content but not for
amplification or recommendation systems
and in exchange for getting section 230
protections for those who don't know
it's what prevents is what enables
platforms to not be liable for bad
content on their platforms
but in exchange for that there has to be
transparency
to the public and to many civil society
groups to be able to say
which things we want to measure about
the use or
or prevalence of certain kinds of
content
so that we can actually do a better job
of regulating them because we don't even
have transparency now about
how bad is the teenage mental health
problem how many users beneath the age
of 16
are using it between two and four in the
morning if we had transparency we could
actually
make them report not to a board of
directors but to a board of the people
based on these metrics that matter to us
in a democratically governed society
oh that is enormous so modifying section
230 in those ways would be
huge because in many ways uh that is
these companies licensed to uh
operate and print money really that's
right you know
and this was written in 96 before any of
these companies even existed like we
couldn't
i'm sure they anticipated youtube and
facebook and tick tock you know many
years later
uh yeah so we need to examine
this license essentially and what you're
suggesting is a difference between
posting content and then spreading
advertising content or
messages or videos that there's some
kind of commercial incentive attached to
so that's a very that's a very
interesting distinction
the other interesting thing you're
attaching to it is to say look
we're going to give you this and in some
cases this franchise is worth you know
billions even trillions of dollars but
in return we get data
they get real data about what the actual
public harms are
because if you compare this to a
negative externality where you look at
you know for example with pollution you
look around and say okay there's a
you know there are negative effects
through climate change and this one we
actually need the data the social media
companies
have in order to measure um a lot of the
harms
that's right and so this is table stakes
this is not the thing that answers the
problems this is the sort of
prerequisite for being able to do
anything a metaphor i often have
anderson so using these
climate change analogies is it's like
facebook is like exxon
but they're the exon of human anxiety
except they also don't just own
the kind of you know extraction of oil
they also own
the entire satellite network that we
have to observe and measure how much co2
so they actually control the measurement
of how bad the problem is
so this is ridiculous it's almost like
it's you know if you take the monopoly
conversation it's a vertically
integrated company that owns both the
measurement
you know either the exclusive access to
measurement of the harm
and also the harm creation that's a
vertically integrated perverse
sort of company there's also other
aspects freedom from manipulation
accountability for harms enabling more
competition and we can to dig into that
because it's less about as you said
magically breaking them up causes the
removal of misinformation or addiction
in society because you still have a race
to the bottom to create
those problems and then also national
security because we haven't talked about
that
that you know while we've been obsessed
you know by some
folks and politicians of protecting our
physical borders
we've been leaving our digital borders
wide open and this is really important
because if russia or china try to fly a
plane into the physical united states
where they try to get across the
passport controls we have
huge billions of dollars invested in
either shooting down that plane or
stopping them at the border but it's
still none of us would accept it
none of us would accept the fact that
you have you have 70 countries right now
that are
uh investing in misinformation and
everyone's like oh you know if you had
70 countries flying planes through our
airspace we'd all be like what the heck
is going on that's exactly right and so
and
so if you think about it as how much of
the surface area of our
of our country's activities happens in
the physical world
and how much of that surface area is
moving into the virtual world
of kind of facebook instagram clicks
advertising email etc
and more and more of our economic
activity is moving from the physical to
the digital but we don't protect the
digital borders
so if russia and china try to fly an
information plane
into the virtual united states instead
of being met by the pentagon to shoot it
down they're met by a facebook algorithm
with a white glove that says yeah
exactly which zip code
or minority group would you like to
target with more divisive information
that can stir up culture wars
so this is a urgent national security
threat that we've been meaning to try to
get
you know more into the agenda because i
think we don't we massively
underestimate the vulnerability of
culture
you know after world war ii you know big
powers like russia
china iran turkey they're not going to
you know attack the united states with
nuclear weapons anymore they can't do
kinetic warfare
and so what would you do you would
actually want to take the divisions in a
country that already exist
walk over their virtual borders and stir
up culture wars and racial
divides everywhere which is exactly what
we're seeing them doing
um we also know that russia has gone
after um ex-us veteran groups and trying
to sow more discontent about
you know uh uh they're not so dark we
know that they're
we know that russia is going after
environmentalist groups um in fact
they actually go after
pro-environmentalists anti-fracking us
advocates like greenpeace and mag and
amplify them because what happens if in
the u.s
we don't frack we have to buy more
foreign oil from where
from russia so there's many different
aspects to this problem but i think what
people need to know
is that this is in all of our interests
it's not a partisan issue
it's really a a global issue and a
national security issue
that affects everyone so tristan
if hypothetically i am part of the
administration
and i call you and say hey do you want
to join the newly christened
department of the attention economy and
uh clean this stuff
up like are you game are we gonna do
this thing if if we can make that happen
and there's a real opportunity
um in the next administration i think i
would have to strongly consider doing
that
well tristan you're a blessing to us
all the fact that you've been fighting
this fight in
sometimes in relative pain and obscurity
uh and now this is
a moment when everyone can look at you
and say he's been onto something this
whole time just like your old colleagues
at google who are like hey i didn't see
it but now i see it
we all see it now which is the first big
step towards solving a problem is
acknowledging its existence and now we
have to solve it as quickly as possible
because time is not on our side
and this stuff's getting nastier more
virulent it's going to make it
impossible for us to
this is the problem that if you don't
solve it you can't solve anything else
that's right but i do think the thing
that gives me hope andrew
is that you know what's what's been
missing is the collective will of the
people and public
pressure and i wish i could show the
world my inbox because
i didn't even have an instagram account
that i hadn't used since 2000 2012
and now suddenly i went from you know no
followers or whatever to something like
50 000 i get messages from all
around the world from people saying i'm
ready to i'm ready to do everything i
can this is too important everyone wants
to solve this problem so i probably feel
like you did
where you're just getting messages from
people around the country saying we got
to solve it and i know that's not enough
we have to actually translate it into
meaningful action and political energy
but i think that the difference between
this and climate change is unlike seeing
the movie inconvenient truth
and then saying well this is going to
happen to my grandkids if this is the
climate change of culture and it's sort
of a disaster for our social fabric
after seeing the movie you turn to that
glass slab in your pocket and you stare
at it 80 more times that day
and you know that it's causing these
problems so i think that this really is
the issue we can all unite around and
that gives me
an incredible hope and i think as you
said you know awareness precedes the
opportunity for choice
i think the question everyone can ask
themselves is instead of my attention
being the commodity we can also ask
what what is worth our attention
individually and also what is worth our
attention
as a as a country um because i think the
current attention economy does not
reflect you know what really matters to
us
none of us would choose this that's for
sure tristan and we're going to have to
actually
decide what to choose if we give
ourselves that chance
so so pumped to reconnect with you
congratulations
on on your organization and movement
and documentary getting to this point
and i'm thrilled to work with you
because we got to solve these problems i
you know one thing i i do get those
messages and i appreciate
the yang yang and the love so much i you
know we should maybe give a name for
your
gang um we do need one actually the
humane gang
yeah humane yeah gang of humans whatever
it is
um but but the challenge now uh just to
give you like uh
uh you know like at least my sense of
things is what you just said is like
look
you're the people then you have this
political energy and then you have a
political system that is not exactly
super high functioning
that's the thing and then you have in
this case in your case
you have these 650 billion dollar
companies or you know multi-billion
dollar companies
who are like the biggest richest they're
like almost countries unto themselves
uh and and when they look up and see our
national government they do not think to
themselves like oh
like um you know these people uh know
what's best for me and my business
like i should really listen to them it's
more
it's more like so so this is like the
popular energy is an enormous
first step but activating our political
machinery to actually
like make these changes and bring some
of these companies to the table
um popular zeal will help because a lot
of the folks
work at these companies like you did a
lot of the folks obviously you know like
have kids themselves or use the services
um but yeah like the the real fight is
coming
yeah well you know i uh i think we have
actually a lot of lessons to learn from
probably people who used to formally
work for you because we do need to build
a movement on the back
of i think what the film is creating um
i think there's so much energy to change
but
uh we we have to channel it in the
appropriate directions and i know
there's some things coming up locally in
california the consumer privacy act um
consumer privacy reform
rights excuse me um and some you know
more action in europe uh but i
i want to encourage people to really get
involved
to you know educate yourself we do have
more resources on humanetech.com
but honestly andrew i'd love to learn
more as well about how do we activate a
movement around this because
it is how we see it i think we have to
organize a constituency that this is the
issue that's beneath other issues
well you and i are going to connect i'm
going to text you
and i want to be a resource to you in
any way i can
um if someone does want to get
energized around your movement is it is
humanetech.com
the best place to go yeah um the best
place to go is humanetech.com
um for those who want to know just how
they take control of the
things and the effects that they saw in
the film there's a take control page
we also have a great podcast called your
undivided attention where we interview
many of the people who are in the film
the social dilemma
but go in depth on you know youtube
recommendations go in depth on russian
disinformation go in depth on
the casino-like slot machine design of
social media
and that's a good place to educate
yourself and we're really working now on
on kind of mobilization so how do we
build those catchment systems
that mobilize people and i would frankly
andrew i would really love to follow up
with you about
um how you did that and who we could
leverage from your movement to help us
because i think
this i think we can really get a large
constituency that's also bipartisan too
done and done oh we are at your disposal
let's give it up for tristan harris
tristan thank you so much brother please
it's such a pleasure to be here andrea i
really really appreciate what you've
done and um
i i'm really excited to follow up i
really think this is so important so
thank you so much for having me me too
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode